[Music]
you kill me
your brother's a dead man you're right
take him alive kill his man
[Music]
i'm just going to guess that the old
knife through the eye is not a popular
focus group uh
moment i yeah i don't know if the focus
groups would like that very much
but that scene is an interesting scene
because they uh um
in in the book those of you read the
books know that it is a somewhat
different scene in the book uh
in the book all of the characters are on
horseback uh you know he is he is riding
back
with jory on their horses uh from the
brothel
and he is accosted by jamie and his men
who are also on horses also is
it is at night and it is during a
rainstorm so the rain is pouring down
all around us
and that is exactly the way that dave
and dan wrote it when they did the
first draft of the script at night in
the rain on horses
and of course as filming time approached
and budget overruns happen
one by one each of these elements got
lost oh
okay well it doesn't have to be during
the rain does it uh
we'll lose that uh do we really need
it to be night it would be fit the
schedule better if it was day you know
and horses do we have to have horses
so we wound up instead of at night in
the rain on horses we wound up on foot
in the day
no nice and dry would have been great to
do it the way it was originally written
very atmospheric and and cool in the
rain and horses but
this way they certainly got it a lot
quicker and it still worked
and i think
the realities of television television
production means you do have to
sometimes make make these uh
changes to fit your budget and your
shooting schedule the
the trick is to know where to draw the
line and and what to
what to fight for uh what is uh
something where you can change the
fundamentals of a scene without harming
the scene
and other changes that
rip machine to shreds because you you're
accidentally ripping out the heart of it
or maybe deliberately ripping out the
heart of it as you make a change to make
it more suitable